الخبر الوارد قبل قليل افاد مراسل الجزيره
ان قوات الاحتلال تطلق النار بكثافه على
مستشفى كمال عدوان في غزه اثناء مؤتمر
صحفي لوزاره الصحه وفي جديد القصف
الاسرائيلي افاد مراسل الجزيره باستشهاد
60 شخصا في غارات اسرائيليه على منازل
شمالي قطاع غزه منذ صباح اليوم وهذه الصور
الخاصه وردتنا من اثار القصف في جباليا
اكد مراسلنا سقوط شهداء وجرحى جراء قصف
مدفعي اسرائيلي استهدف منازل المواطنين في
احياء الزيتون والشجاع والدرج والصبره شرق
مدينه غزه كما افاد مراسل الجزيره بتنفيذ
طيران الاحتلال غارتين على منطقه معن جنوب
شرق خانيونس كما تعربت منطقه بني سهيله
شرق خان يونس الى قصف اسرائيلي عنيف واكد
مراسلنا سقوط شهداء
ومصابين في قصف اسرائيلي استهدف مدرسه
تؤوي نازحين غرب خان يونس جنوبيه قطاع
غزه